l'uruguay était jusqu'ici le premier et
seul pays au monde à avoir légalisé le
cannabis à des fins récréatives
c'était il ya cinq ans des citoyens sur
goyen de plus de 18 ans ont droit à 40
grammes de cannabis par mois qu'ils
peuvent consommer dans des clubs privés
où s'ils sont dûment inscrits ils
peuvent acheter leurs 40 g dans
certaines pharmacies autorisée ils ont
le droit aussi de faire pousser jusqu'à
six plants de cannabis par foyer ce que
la légalisation a changé c'est l'opinion
publique lors de l'adoption de la loi
64% des uruguayens peuple réputé assez
conservateurs étaient contre cinq ans
plus tard ils sont à 61 % pour la
consommation de cannabis a augmenté en
uruguay selon l'organisme officiel
monitor cannabis de 2014 à 2017
elle est passée de 9% de la population à
15 et demi pour cent ce qui est à peu
près celle du canada une augmentation
comparable aux autres régions du monde
sur la base des chiffres des nations
unies monitor cannabis conclu qu'à
travers le monde
ni la légalisation ni la prohibition non
une influence quelconque sur le niveau
de consommation en uruguay la
consommation a moins augmenté chez les
jeunes que chez les femmes deux fois
plus et chez les plus de 35 ans celle
des 55 à 65 ans a augmenté de 229% le
cannabis serait donc un truc de vieux ça
se discute
aux etats unis usage du cannabis est
légal dans neuf états mais il reste
illégal au niveau fédéral pour
accommoder ses états barack obama avait
mis le mémorandum cola donald trump a
donné l'ordre à son procureur général
jeff sessions de l'annuler mais sans
conséquence jusqu'ici l'état washington
a été le premier en 2012 à légaliser le
cannabis pour des adultes de plus de 21
ans possession permise d'une once soit
28 grammes sans droit d'en cultiver le
colorado est suivie une once par
individu de plus de 21 ans droit de
cultiver chez soi jusqu'à six plants le
marché du cannabis sous toutes formes de
consommation y est considérable 1
milliard 300 millions de dollars en 2018
ailleurs dans le monde la hollande a été
le pays pionnier en termes de
consommation de cannabis
même si la possession reste illégal
depuis 40 ans elle est toléré jusqu'à 5
grammes et la consommation est permise
dans les fameuses coffee shops licenciés
le portugal est un modèle unique depuis
13 ans la loi des féminalise la
possession de petites quantités de
toutes les drogues
si un individu se fait prendre on lui
confie ce que sa drogue et une
commission de dissuasion évaluera son
niveau d'action en vue d'un éventuel
traitement dans les amériques
aucun pays n'est encore allé aussi loin
que le canada et l'uruguay mais en
général
en amérique latine on risque peu d'ennui
en consommant du cannabis
il suffit de le faire un peu
discrètement jean michel leprince sera
du canada à montréal